في ماوي في لاهاينا، تنظر إلى هذا
الدمار صفًا بعد صف تلو الآخر من
المنازل والشركات المتفحمة،
وتنظر الآن إلى لقطة طائرات بدون طيار هناك في
لاهينا وهي تنظر بعيدًا عن المياه وكل
ما يمكنك رؤيته لمسافة طويلة جدًا هو
المباني المحترقة تلك  هل توجد شركات
هناك،
يمنحك هذا الفيديو بدون طيار
منظورًا كبيرًا حقًا لما يمر به الناس
ولماذا تطلب السلطات من
الناس محاولة الابتعاد عن هذه
المنطقة بالذات على الرغم من أن ماوي لا
تزال تعمل بالمناسبة، إنها
مجرد منطقة  لاهينا
ولاهاينا الكبرى ليس عدد القتلى الذي
علمنا به الليلة قد ارتفع إلى
53 شخصًا على الأقل ولكن لا يزال هناك
أشخاص في عداد المفقودين، لذا يحذر المسؤولون من
أن عدد القتلى من المرجح أن يزيد
عدد الأشخاص الأربعة في عداد المفقودين في
هذه المرحلة إلى ألف